Chinese officials are in Washington this
week to negotiate president Trump's
long-promised trade deal but there's
growing pressure on the Trump
administration to sanction China for
what Secretary of State Mike Pompeo
called the worst human rights abuses
since the 1930s CBS News has obtained a
letter sent by a bipartisan group of
lawmakers today faulting the
administration and urging action to stop
mass arrests of Muslims senior foreign
affairs correspondent and Face the
Nation moderator Margaret Brennan is at
the State Department Margaret do morning
good morning while rounding up religious
minorities and putting them in
internment camps is something the world
said should never happen again
but it is happening right now in China
too more than 1 million Muslims and so
far the Trump administration has not
taken action to stop it
we are the voice of voiceless people
American gold Chariho juh is from
Shenzhen province home to China's eager
Muslim minority Chinese authorities have
taken two dozen of her relatives to
internment camps
my brother detained in 2017 September
after I heard that from my mom I was
asking her can I just talk this issue
openly and she was asking me actually
begging me says I already lost one child
I don't want to lost another one do you
know if they're alive
no as a Radio Free Asia correspondent in
Washington shotgun she reports on what
is happening back home video posted to
social media appears to show the inside
of these camps which the State
Department believes are designed for
mass detention to erase religious and
ethnic identities they even have a
camera in the bathroom so 24/7 they
watching you Beijing blames it's Muslim
minority for several attacks such as
this 2014 one and says it is rapidly
building these facilities to combat
terrorism today a bipartisan group of
law
acres including Senator Bob Menendez are
calling for sanctions on Chinese
officials and cautioning US companies we
need to make sure that US companies are
not engaged in providing the resources
and the wherewithal to allow the Chinese
to oppress its own people now gold chera
did meet last week with Secretary of
State Pompeo but the lawmakers who
authored this letter say words aren't
enough they want inspectors allowed into
the camps and they want to make sure US
companies aren't selling surveillance
technology to China to help them with
these abuses Gayle all right Margaret
thank you very much